there's a saying the best time to plant
a tree is 20 years ago the second best
time is now but what happens when the
cost of planting those new trees is
chopping down others that are decades
old
well that's exactly what's happened in
Plymouth more than a hundred mature
trees cut down for a regeneration
project to transform the city center and
supposedly make it more attractive well
people there aren't Furious about this
and in Sheffield it's a very familiar
story an independent inquiry said
Sheffield council's destruction of
thousands of trees as part of a street
Improvement project was misjudged
people in these two cities are really
upset and trees have become a huge local
issue let's talk about why and just
what's going on I'm Sally Lockwood and
this is the Sky News Daily
I'll be speaking to campaigners in both
Plymouth and Sheffield but first let's
speak to Nick Martin our people in
politics correspondent
well who would have thought who would
have actually thought that trees would
have become such a big political issue
but we've learned a lot from what
happened in Sheffield
[Music]
there's a saying the best time to plant
a tree is 20 years ago the second best
time is now but what happens when the
cost of planting those new trees is
chopping down others that are decades
old well that's exactly what's happened
in Plymouth more than a hundred mature
trees cut down for a regeneration
project to transform the city center and
supposedly make it more attractive will
people there are Furious about this and
in Sheffield it's a very familiar story
an independent inquiry said Sheffield
council's destruction of thousands of
trees as part of a street Improvement
project was misjudged people in these
two cities are really upset and trees
have become a huge local issue let's
talk about why and just what's going on
I'm Sally Lockwood and this is the Sky
News Daily
I'll be speaking to campaigners in both
Plymouth and Sheffield but first let's
speak to Nick Martin our people and
politics correspondent
well who would have thought who would
have actually thought that trees would
have become such a big political issue
but we've learned a lot from what
happened in Sheffield and Plymouth and
other parts of the country that trees
are actually quite a big issue when it
comes to how our towns and cities are
regenerated and they actually pose quite
a big sort of headache for councils when
it comes to the amount of money that it
costs to regenerate towns and this
crucial issue of whether it's worth
getting rid of old trees or looking
after them or whether it's actually
easier to chop them down and plant new
ones now Nick Sky News learned that
National highways admitted more than
half a million trees have died beside a
single 21-mile stretch of new
carriageway this is something Sky News
climate cost podcast with Tom Heep
covered last week next to the A14
outside Cambridge we've seen a document
from National highways that says over
half a million trees on this 20-mile
bypass alone have died since they were
planted a few years ago
they felt a load of healthy trees they
planted wait for it 850 000 trees half
of them have died it's gonna cost nearly
3 million to replant them lots have gone
wrong with these projects and you know
we we do need to learn lessons from it
this is a huge headache for councils but
we are seeing this cropping up more and
more you know when you put it like that
it is heartbreaking for so many people
who care about the environment who care
about these beautiful old trees which
let's be honest most of them or a lot of
them outlive us
um why is it that councils are opting to
cut down old trees and plant new ones
well look in the natural environment
planting new trees can actually be more
expensive and require more work that's
in the natural environment but think
about cities trees are enveloped by the
human world Pavements curbs concrete
roads you name it it can often be more
expensive to keep an old tree than
replace it with all the building working
it might have to be done around it than
to just chop it down and plant smaller
sapling trees and in regeneration
schemes where money and time are key to
successful projects councils are under
pressure to deliver reduce the kind of
disruption in towns that can lead
councils to lean away from protecting
established Urban trees and make quite
mad decisions really to cut good trees
down because it's actually cheaper than
to reap to look to look after them we'll
hear more from Nick later on in the
podcast but one place Nick mentioned
that's been facing problems is Plymouth
where more than 100 mature trees were
felt to make way for a regeneration of
the Armada way that's half-mile
Promenade like area in the city center
now a council document said 60
60 of residents didn't want this plan to
go ahead and although the work was put
on hold in November last year
suddenly the council went ahead with
cutting down the trees they were only
stopped after a court injunction by
which time most of the trees were
already down the council leader who made
that decision has now resigned Penny
Tarrant is a campaigner of save the
Trees of armada way also known as straw
this is something that's been going on
in Plymouth since 2018 and we have a
lovely
um kind of urban Forest quite sort of
semi-natural area or we did have
um right in the center of the city which
is in the main shopping area it was sort
of left over from post-war development
of Plymouth was fairly flattened during
the wars so it's a big wide Boulevard
and it had wonderful planting of trees
which people have grown attached to
since it was planted in the 60s people
loved the trees so when it emerged that
um there was this big plan for
redevelopment in 2018 there was an
initial consultation by the council
which didn't mention anything about
felling of trees but obviously people
welcomed some investment in the city
center for regeneration and then it
emerged that all nearly all the trees
136 South 160 or were going to be lost
these are mature trees and
um people just hadn't been aware of that
in the past and word got around and
straw was set up they initiated a
petition which grew and grew very
quickly people were horrified and it
reached 16
000 signatories
um we presented its Council we managed
to get a stay of execution for the trees
while they
conducted what they called a meaningful
Community engagement process involving a
questionnaire what did people think
about the scheme so you have this big
beautiful Promenade like area in the
center of Plymouth which has pretty old
trees along it and as part of this
regeneration plan for the area the
council said they would they would need
to fell the majority of these old trees
so so obviously campaigners like
yourself have have signed a petition and
campaign to protect the trees
but they've still been chopped down tell
me about that moment where you realized
that they'd been chopped down yeah well
they Community engagement showed
overwhelmingly people didn't want this
to happen and the day that they
announced that so I think and now also
later they were moving in these huge
tree munching machines which were used
usually in big forests
um people rushed down there to try and
see if we could prevent them the felling
but they outmaneuvered us they had huge
police numbers they had dogs they had
security guards they still carried on
felling the trees and over five hours I
think 110 were lost in those few hours
behind the scenes and an injunction
managed to be produced just after one
o'clock in the morning at that point
they had to cease filling the trees now
as you said the majority of Plymouth
residents were campaigning to protect
the trees some 68 didn't want the plans
to go ahead
if I'm not mistaken
did the fetting begin in the early hours
of the morning while the roads were
quiet and people were asleep in their
homes tell me about that the felling
period was immediately that they
published the executive order by
councilor Richard Bingley
um immediately then the work commenced
so it was around six o'clock by which
time all the shops had shut and
communities were leaving the city center
it was all behind
um high fences and as I say people tried
desperately to access the site but were
unable to but it went on until the
injunction was produced at one o'clock
in the morning and by that point how
much damage had been done well 110 trees
mature trees had been felled
there were Birds nesting in there we've
seen a dead check on the ground it was
merciless in the way they treated the
trees in their complete disregard
regards for public opinion we've
approached the council ourselves um to
to get obviously their response to all
this
um but did they ever try and explain to
you or did you ever ask why old trees
why mature trees wouldn't feature as
part of this regeneration plan who
wouldn't want beautiful old trees as
part of their Town Center I mean the
trees have been left and neglected for
some time now we asked them this on
numerous occasions in numerous ways we
have many
Tree Experts who are associated with our
charity who asked in you know technical
language what situation was we've read
in detail the tree report that shows
that despite their interpretation of it
the majority the vast majority of the
trees were healthy and had you know 20
plus years of life so and that's been
demonstrated now we've seen the fellow
trees we've seen inside the the trunks
there's no evidence of disease or Decay
so any seminal also trees were
recommended for felling but it's clear
from the start that they wanted a blank
canvas and despite having a plan for
trees and a climate emergency
declaration in the city that states that
any development should start from the
Viewpoint of incorporating mature trees
what's the reaction been like in
Plymouth people are heartbroken and
we've had vigils trees we've had
children writing poems and you know what
what message does this send to them that
they can't trust people in authority to
do the right thing it's about their
future it seems to be big business
that's driving this at any cost they
want uniform fast digit trees that
um you know look neat and tidy but on a
biodiverse habitats that and there's
been no regard for the the habitat that
these trees provide is and all the
wildlife and and biodiversity in that
area it's just been cast aside now penny
at the time of of recording this the
council leader announced that he was
planning to step down
um in response to all this this has had
huge repercussions to the city we were
all pulling together to try and make it
a green and blue City we were all
wonderful natural setting by the Sea
we're going to have to be spending the
next few years trying to put that
straight so people see what a wonderful
City it really is and try and save the
remaining trees if we can or at least
have as much of a say as possible in how
the scheme now goes forward
foreign
has also been a similar Battleground in
this fight between councilors and
campaigners over the city's trees in
2012 the local Authority signed a
25-year contract with a private firm
which included the instruction to remove
and replace Seventeen and a half
thousand trees that's around half the
trees in Sheffield
eleven years later an independent review
of the council's actions said they
failed to recognize people's love of
those trees and that replacing mature
ones with saplings was seen as vandalism
Eve wood is an editor of a film called
the felling which explores Sheffield's
trioxin Fiasco and the protests behind
it
yeah
they can't preach that we need to
improve our quality at the same time as
chopping down trees
and for about two years you could see
the yellow ribbons around the trees that
puts up the trees were on the thread all
around the city you could see which
trees were now fulfelling because they
kept putting yellow ribbons around the
city
and then the council took them down at
night and then the protesters took them
put them off again the next morning
there's actually one of the trees I
really liked he was called the Lilac was
beautiful it had owls in it it was
massive it probably hunt over the years
old I'm not sure how old it was and I I
just came back from work one day I
worked to Nottingham at that point and I
wasn't involved in the protest because I
couldn't
um and I came back at the end of the day
and Delilah was gone and it was awful it
was just you know it really is
devastating you know people have been
traumatized by it they still traumatized
but when they hear a chainsaw it still
gets them now it's six years later and
and the name of your film Eve is the
felling tell us what sort of a
difference has it made
it's definitely just raised awareness
one of the main thing that I thought my
motivation was to make this film was
that this is just outrageous it just
doesn't make any sense to cut down
healthy trees especially now when the
world is just having an environmental
crisis and so when I saw the footage I
thought this is just outrageous how far
they went the length they went to arrest
people and then uh put an injunction
settled with courts threatened for
people to jail I live around the corner
from where the film opens they've been
protesting for two years to try and to
persuade the cows to stop the trees
being dropped down I think lots of
people were really really really upset
because what happened is that they tried
to tell the council say please don't
chop this tree down I've got a
relationship with this tree I like this
tree I would and look at it every day
and they basically ended up chopping
these trees down in front of these
protesters
let's go back to Nick now are people in
politics correspondent
so councils like Sheffield and more
recently Plymouth appear to have been
really unable to resist the extreme
option of felling healthy trees and for
both councils it's not only been a
natural disaster but it's been a PR
disaster in the middle of the night
powering up the chainsaws chopping down
the trees regardless of what people
think about it yeah it certainly felt uh
very clandestine in the manner in which
it was carried out both in Plymouth and
in Sheffield
are other councils sitting up and
listening and realizing that this issue
matters to people
so this goes back to money I think and
and a respect for public debate look at
Sheffield they lied to Residents you
know on one occasion in Autumn 2016
contractors began work at 4 45 in the
morning they dragged residents out of
bed to move their cars so they could
chop trees down and none of the
residents wanted chopping down they
deliberately misled residents according
to the independent review Sheffield
Council misled the high court not once
but twice why would a council stray into
such murky territory over trees I don't
know it's actually not that clear at
best it's sort of bad leadership and a
lack of respect for the residents they
serve at worst it's a complete disregard
for the natural environment that people
want around them and that's why you know
people live in nice tree-lined areas and
sheffields are good examples you've got
load of them it's not clear why councils
are ignoring their residence and we have
got example after example of it public
consultation you know we hear it a lot
but it is important people should have
their say what we've seen in Sheffield
and Plymouth is a complete sort of
ignoring of that to the extent that
trees have been chopping down in the
dead of night and what if Plymouth or
Sheffield Council said in response to to
these controversies in their areas well
I mean Sheffield for the last few years
have had their hands up I mean they've
constantly already acknowledged that
they got things wrong in the handling of
Street the street trees dispute and
apologized again and they've they have
to be fair try to move move on uh with
that I mean in May last year Sheffield
was actually named Tree City of the year
I think there's been a lot of soul
searching going on in Sheffield about
what went wrong and how they went about
it I mean the same can't be said for
Plymouth who only recently have
undergone this sort of similar process
having not seemingly learned the lessons
from uh from Sheffield I mean we we've
heard very briefly from Plymouth they've
said they can't really comment because
they're actually legal proceedings
ongoing and they've been advised by
their legal counsel not to provide any
other statement I mean what a mess
they've got themselves into they've lost
their Council leader they've probably
lost the respect of an awful lot of
residents all because they didn't listen
we've got local elections coming up soon
Nick how much do you think we may see
candidates and politicians
showing that they are going to try and
protect these older trees and make make
it a priority and and listen to people
well you know my job you know as people
and politics corresponding is to merge
these diffuse these two ideas together
now I think that people want to live in
healthy uh natural environments as much
as possible and that even includes our
inner cities so I think it is always
going to be a big political issue you
know look in some areas it'll be a big
issue I'm sure that people of Plymouth
right now will want to express their
anger or views at the polls it's still
very raw it's still a big story I think
that though in other areas it might not
be a massive priority you know if you're
struggling to pay your bills or feed the
kids you might not be too preoccupied
about trees nationally you know in
general elections trees actually crop up
in all the manifestos in 2019 labor said
they wanted to plant two billion trees a
year the conservatives 30 million more
trees every year the lib Dems 60 million
each the green 700 million trees by
2030. so you get the idea they all want
voters to know that they're big into
planting trees so so I do think
Sheffield and Plymouth cases are caution
retails for councils of The Perils of
not listening to people and that might
manifest itself in the local elections
in may we might just see people saying
you know what we want a tree in our
street and if it's healthy please don't
cut it down in addition to Plymouth City
council's response to us they published
a statement on their website too that
reads all but 16 of the trees due to be
felt are now down in total 110 trees
were felled but an injunction served at
1am meant we had to Halt The Works
entirely the plan had been to remove all
the felled trees and shave off and make
safe any stumps along the main
pedestrian routes once all the trees had
come down before the start of the
working day unfortunately the injunction
meant we had to stop work we await
applications from the claimant as
directed by the court
my thanks to Nick Penny and Eve and to
you for tuning in to the Sky News Daily
with me Sally Lockwood you can also hear
more about trees on the national highway
on Sky News climate cast with Tom Heep
in our episode Dead wood why were more
than half a million trees left to die
this episode was produced by soiler
Apparition with Alex Eden the editor is
Philly Beaumont
foreign